[Aplausos]
[Música]
es argentina virtual y mediática que
planteó que odiábamos a las fuerzas
armadas por dios nosotros los peronistas
contra los militares somos el único
partido político vigente la argentina
fundado por un general
en el terreno de la política argentina
es algo así como las bodas reales para
la prensa rosa es imposible mentar que
acaparen toda la atención y todas las
portadas en este caso muchos vídeos de
visual política y que queréis que os
diga no es para menos desde un punto de
vista político el caso argentino es tan
apasionante como para un amante del
fútbol una final de la champions entre
el real madrid y el barça
[Música]
[Aplausos]
precisamente por eso hasta la fecha
hemos publicado ya más de 15 vídeos
sobre el país del tango vídeos en los
que hemos tocado un montón de temas
diferentes pero los que sin embargo nos
faltaba echar un vistazo a uno de los
temas políticos más típicos del país los
sindicatos y su enorme poder en la
política argentina
[Música]
pues bien en este vídeo vamos a ver
hasta dónde llega realmente el poder de
los sindicatos pero antes antes tenemos
que ver dónde empezó todo
[Música]
argentina de los sueños
queridos amigos si nos estáis viendo
desde la argentina es posible que
penséis que toda esta historia de los
sindicatos nació con el peronismo los
años 40 sin embargo nada más lejos de la
realidad
la historia del sindicalismo en
argentina es mucho pero que mucho más
larga para conocerla tenemos que
remontarnos ni más ni menos que hasta
finales del siglo 19
en esa época argentina atravesaba sus
años dorados peleaba por ser el país más
rico del planeta de las inversiones
llegaban a raudales y millones y
millones de personas elegían este lugar
para iniciar una nueva vida
de hecho durante las últimas décadas del
siglo 19 argentina fue el segundo país
de todo el mundo que mayor número de
inmigrantes recibió tan solo por detrás
de los mismísimos eeuu en esa época del
sueño americano era tan argentino como
estadounidense
y amigos fue en ese momento cuando los
primeros sindicatos empezaron a surgir
fueron impulsados por los propios
inmigrantes que llegaban al país que los
utilizaban como una forma de organizarse
para mejorar sus condiciones de vida en
un país que no conocían y donde la
mayoría aún no contaban con derechos
políticos
[Música]
de esta forma poco a poco los sindicatos
fueron creciendo y cobrando más y más
influencia por ejemplo en la década de
los años 20 la fortaleza económica de
argentina junto a las reivindicaciones
de todos estos sindicatos hicieron que
se comenzaran a implantar las primeras
medidas respecto a la duración de la
jornada laboral el trabajo de los niños
o los derechos de los trabajadores
sin embargo el auténtico punto de
inflexión de toda esta historia se
produjo unos años más tarde el día 4 de
junio de 1943 se produjo un golpe de
estado que cambiaría la historia de la
argentina para siempre un poco tiempo
después del golpe el entonces coronel
juan domingo perón fue puesto al frente
de la nueva secretaría de trabajo el
coronel perón se había formado la italia
de los años 30 recordemos la italia del
estado fascista de benito mussolini
durante esos años entre pizza risottos y
espaguetis perón descubrió lo importante
que podía llegar a ser organizar desde
el mismo poder al movimiento obrero
[Música]
eso fue exactamente lo que hizo desde el
departamento de trabajo lentamente sin
prisa pero sin pausa fue cooptando a los
sindicatos
empezó por los más pequeños les ofreció
beneficios a cambio de compromisos y
acuerdos con el gobierno o mejor dicho
con el mismo
[Música]
de este modo pero fue construyendo toda
una red de sindicatos que controlaba y
que eran leales de hecho cuanto más bien
era un sindicato más beneficio recibía
del gobierno todo esto puso a perón en
una posición privilegiada de repente se
había convertido en el político más
influyente del país y eso eso fue lo que
le terminó llevando a la casa rosada- la
casa blanca argentina
por supuesto cuando pero se convirtió en
presidente impulsó aún más esta
estrategia política hasta que de facto
la mayoría de los sindicatos pasaron a
formar parte del propio partido
peronista de hecho los sindicatos de
corte socialista o comunista que se
negaban a jurar lealtad a perón pues
fueron perseguidos y en no pocas
ocasiones intervino a sindicatos
rebeldes que de esa forma pasaban a
estar bajo el control oficial estás
conmigo o contra mí si juras lealtad a
perón zanahoria sino palo
y no sólo eso durante sus años en el
poder pero nacional hizo un montón de
empresas y contrató un montón de
empleados públicos con enormes
beneficios laborales un proceso que en
gran medida era controlado por los
propios sindicatos leales a perón eran
su punta de lanza cuando en 1955 pero
aún fue derrocado por un nuevo golpe
militar y el partido peronista y el
propio perón fueron proscritos los
sindicatos se convirtieron en la correa
de transmisión de la influencia
peronista en la argentina se
convirtieron en la fuerza principal de
oposición a la dictadura una dictadura
que sin embargo les iba a conceder su
mayor privilegio
en 1970 tras una insurrección popular
conocida como el cordobazo el general
juan carlos onganía que en aquel momento
dirigía el país hizo por los sindicatos
algo que ni siquiera el propio verón se
había atrevido a hacer les otorgó la
administración de las obras sociales el
servicio de salud de los trabajadores es
decir esto supuso poner en manos de los
sindicatos argentinos cientos y cientos
de millones de dólares sin ningún tipo
de control externo
amigos amigas fue precisamente aquí
cuando los sindicatos argentinos se
convirtieron en algunos de los
sindicatos más poderosos del mundo
organizaciones dirigidas por una elite
que se hizo intocable atentos
[Música]
será algo histórico
argentina qué es
los derechos sociales de los
trabajadores y eso significó el
nacimiento de las organizaciones
sindicales en las cuales creo
profundamente la nueva monarquía
de repente los sindicatos argentinos se
convirtieron en instrumentos muy
poderosos tenían influencia política una
gran capacidad de movilización y
controlaban millones y millones de
dólares desde entonces ese peso no ha
hecho más que crecer para que os hagáis
una idea hoy en día entre 17 y 20
millones de argentinos pagan y reciben
atención médica de los servicios de
salud sindicales y no sólo eso con el
paso de los años estas organizaciones
han expandido sus tentáculos mucho más
allá incluso controlan hoteles
universidades y medios de comunicación
amigos esto hace de los argentinos los
sindicatos más poderosos del planeta
forman un imperio sin embargo espera
hace un momento porque todo esto entraña
también algunos problemas y precisamente
uno de ellos tiene que ver con el
control es decir me explico hablamos de
organizaciones enormes con presupuestos
millonarios que se gestionan con muy
pocos controles
de esta forma si estás al frente de un
sindicato te conviertes en una de las
personas más importantes de la argentina
de repente tienes acceso a un montón de
influencia y dinero
todo el mundo te coge el teléfono
escucha lo que tienes que decir
prácticamente eres intocable muchas
personas a las que has ido colocando
promocionando en diferentes puestos
dependen de ti y como vamos a ver
incluso todo el mundo quiere hacer
negocios contigo así que la pregunta es
por qué demonios dejarlo
amigos en argentina los sindicatos se
han convertido en una especie de nuevos
partidos políticos con exactamente los
mismos incentivos perversos queréis un
ejemplo puedes fijaros los líderes
sindicales de la mayoría de los gremios
o básicamente los mismos desde hace más
de 30 años supuestamente hay elecciones
pero claro cuando llevas tanto tiempo al
frente de una organización puedes
controlar todos los resortes es
exactamente lo mismo que ocurre con los
gobiernos y el motivo que explica que
muchas democracias cuenten con
limitación de mandatos para que ningún
político pues tenga la tentación de
perpetuarse en el poder pero veamos
algunos ejemplos
ahí tenemos el caso de ramón baldassini
de la federación de obreros y empleados
de correos y telecomunicaciones estuvo
al frente del sindicato ni más ni menos
que 55 años desde 1963
omar viviani secretario general de los
peones de taxi más de 35 años
amadeo gente del sindicato de los
trabajadores municipales más de 35 años
guillermo pereyra del sindicato del
petróleo más de 35 años o el de rodolfo
daer del sector de la alimentación más
de 33 años
y
más de 35 años para que os hagáis una
idea estos tipos llevan al mando más
tiempo que cualquier dictador del
planeta a excepción de teodoro obiang
vamos que como viene se entere hasta el
mismo deja el poder hacer las maletas y
se va a la argentina a meter esa
sindicalista vaya tela y ojo porque
estos son tan sólo algunos ejemplos
al final no importa que cambie el país
las condiciones económicas o los
gobiernos los mandamases sindicales
siguen siendo los mismos en argentina es
habitual que estos líderes pasen décadas
al frente de los sindicatos incluso
sábado el caso de líderes sindicales que
han dejado el poder a familiares
directos en argentina han cambiado los
partidos la dirigencia empresarial las
fuerzas armadas hasta la iglesia pero
los sindicatos siguen en manos de los
mismos hace 30 años como lo logran
porque son funcionales al poder hasta
los militares pactaron con ellos siempre
existió la sensación de que si los
sindicalistas no se puede gobernar
argentina ricardo carpena periodista
argentino como os podéis imaginar todo
esto tiene consecuencias los sindicatos
dejan de ser organizaciones plurales y
se convierten en estructuras jerárquicas
además el tiempo pasa las cosas cambian
pero estas estructuras no consiguen
adaptarse y por supuesto al final hay
tantos intereses creados y al final pues
no se sabe muy bien que joaquín díaz
entre se está defendiendo
pero claro puede que alguno de vosotros
esté pensando pero enrique con
sindicatos tan fuertes y tan influyentes
seguro seguro que los trabajadores
argentinos son los más protegidos del
mundo verdad pues no lo cierto es que no
[Música]
la crisis constante en la que vive el
país y las enormes tasas de inflación
han hecho que los salarios reales es
decir el poder adquisitivo de los
trabajadores argentinos se ve estancado
desde hace décadas y no sólo eso hay
poco trabajo el desempleo es elevado y
casi el 40 por ciento de todos los
empleados que hay en el país son
trabajadores informales es decir
trabajadores con mucha menos seguridad y
muchos menos derechos
vamos en otras palabras que si
tuviéramos que evaluar a estos
sindicatos o sus resultados y su
influencia en la política argentina creo
que las notas iban a ser tan malas que
por lo menos iban a pasar los próximos
diez veranos metiendo codos
y ojo a ver que los conozcan muchos de
vosotros yo no estoy diciendo que el
problema sea que haya o no haya
sindicatos para nada sino que tal vez
tener las estructuras tan grandes tan
poderosas tan anquilosadas y con tantos
intereses creados al final sólo hace que
cambiar el rumbo sea prácticamente una
misión imposible a las pruebas me remito
pero amigos tanto dinero y tanto poder
en organizaciones como estas también
conllevan más problemas que no saben por
qué es además como somos peronistas
creemos este en la articulación entre el
capital y el trabajo
y los grandes capos queridos amigos
durante los últimos años los sindicatos
argentinos se han visto sacudidos por
más escándalos que marcelo odebrecht y
ahora alguno de los grandes reyes han
caído
ese es el caso por ejemplo de omar
caballo suárez quien fuera jefe sindical
de los trabajadores de los puertos y uno
de los sindicalistas favoritos de
cristina fernández de kirchner caballo
suárez ha sido procesado por asociación
ilícita coacción agravada y
administración fraudulenta durante la
investigación aparecieron muchos grandes
lujos su domicilio ubicado en una de las
zonas más caras de buenosaires yates
habanos botellas de champán
vamos el bueno de caballo suárez vivía a
lo grande
otro ejemplo lo tenemos en el caso de
juan pablo pata medina fue detenido en
el año 2017 por asociación ilícita al
lavado de dinero y extorsión te calcula
que tan sólo los cinco años anteriores a
su detención hizo operaciones por valor
de más de diez millones de dólares
coches inmuebles joyas en su casa de
este líder sindical tenía incluso una
máquina de contar dinero además de un
montón de coches de lujo para que os
hagáis una idea de lo que estamos
hablando en la trama se encontraron más
de 100 coches tres millones de dólares
en joyas y hasta un avión y un
helicóptero vamos que el tipo parecía
más un personaje salido del gta que un
líder sindical
[Música]
marcelo balcedo otro de los líderes
sindicales del sector de la educación
también fue pillado detenido en
noviembre de 2018 se le incautaron
cuentas bancarias y dinero en efectivo
por más de 7 millones de dólares entre
sus propiedades figuraban dos aviones un
yate varios porches un ferrari ya hasta
un mercedes mclaren el tipo tenía
incluso su propio zoológico y más de 35
empleados a su servicio vamos que vivía
como un marajá
en fin estos son sólo tres ejemplos de
una larga lista muchos líderes
sindicales utilizaron su posición para
amasar auténticas fortunas y vivir como
reyes y lo hicieron durante décadas con
total impunidad y mientras el país
pasaba de una crisis a otra amigos los
sindicatos pueden jugar un papel
importante pero realmente es necesario
que controlen tanto dinero no debería
caso el gobierno argentino exigirles más
transparencia y controles para evitar
que las élites se perpetúen en el poder
no deberían hacer autocrítica y
reconocer tal vez que su papel durante
las últimas décadas ha contribuido a
muchos de los problemas que hoy tiene la
argentina al fin y al cabo los
sindicatos argentinos han sido fuentes
defensores de políticas como más
impuestos más proteccionismo y más
regulaciones laborales políticas que han
hecho un daño enorme al país no ha
llegado acaso la hora de cambiar en fin
amigos espero que este vídeo se haya
resultado interesante si ha sido así no
olvidéis darle al botón de like
suscribiros si aún no lo habéis hecho
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima y ustedes
no saben por qué es además como somos
peronistas creemos este en la
articulación entre el capital y el
trabajo
[Música]